Okay.
Let's get started.
So, welcome back everyone. So, today
we're going to talk about parallelism.
And remember in the last week we
introduced how to make a single GPU go
fast by writing kernels, and we really
looked inside this GPU.
And this week we're going to talk about
how to leverage multiple GPUs to make
your code go even faster.
Um so, the picture you should have in
your head is something like this.
So, for the last week we focused on one
of these boxes where you have your GPU.
Uh remember you have your high bandwidth
memory HBM, um L2 cache, L1 cache,
registers, and a bunch of streaming
multiple uh
streaming multiprocessors.
Um so, now the picture gets extended
because instead of having one GPU, you
might have four, you might have a
thousand GPUs, and those are going to be
connected. Um and I'll talk later about
how those GPUs are going to uh get
connected. And then you're going to have
to figure out how to leverage all of
this compute uh to train models.
So, in both cases, meaning both in the
single GPU case and in the multi GPU
case as we'll talk about today,
the situation is kind of similar if you
zoom out, which is that the compute um
the arithmetic logic uh units, the
tensor cores, so on, is far away from
your data. And far away for a single GPU
means all the way over here in uh HBM.
And and now, if you have multiple GPUs,
the thing that you need here might be
all the way on a different GPU. And
you're going to have to shovel uh that
over somehow.
But the same principles are going to be
the same because the game is to
orchestrate the computation to try to
avoid data transfer bottlenecks. It's
very easy to use a ton of GPUs, but it's
hard to use them effectively.
So, um
taking a little bit of liberty, we can
think about the generalized hierarchy
where at the at the
sort of local level next to the um the
SMs is a single node single GPU where
you have um an L1 cache shared memory.
This was the fastest. And then you had
um HPM
which we lamented was so slow, but in
this lecture HPM is going to be
considered fast. Um now we're going to
uh think about the single node multi GPU
setting where the GPUs are going to be
connected via NVLink and NVLink switch.
Um and then finally the multi node and
multi GPU where we have to resort to
InfiniBand and um Ethernet depending on
what uh network you have.
Okay. So,
last week uh we talked about various um
tricks for um
improving memory accesses, uh fusion,
and tiling. Read into shared memory, do
everything you as much as you can, and
then write it back out. Um and this week
uh we're going to talk about how you can
reduce the amount of communication
um across uh GPUs by uh replicating and
and and sharding appropriately.
So, so why do you do GPU multi GPUs? Um
the the obvious answer is well, you want
to scale, but to put a uh finer point on
it, there's really two reasons. One is
that your parameters or activations or
gradients and optimizer state don't fit
on the HPM memory of uh a single GPU.
So, B200 has 192 GB. If you're training
a 1 trillion parameter model, that's not
going to fit on a single uh GPU.
And the other reason is that even if
your model could fit on single GPU, you
might want to leverage more GPUs by uh
splitting everything up to train faster.
So, sometimes there will be kind of some
decisions to be made because
um you could fit everything on GPUs, but
you have fewer uh cores. Uh
But, if you spread out, then you're
going to have to pay the communication
bandwidth.
Right. So, that's some calculation
you're going to have to do to figure out
um how to parallelize.
Okay. So, just one note here is that um
so far this lecture is Python, you
execute it, and you can just show
everything. Now, this lecture, if you
run this directly, it uses
multiprocessing. Um
but, when I trace through it, I'm
putting in some sort of like special
single process mode. So, if you want to
see the standard out for this lecture,
re- um run in the multiprocessing setup,
um you can click here, and I'll show
this as we go through the lecture. But,
just remember as we step through this
lecture, we're not actually doing
multiprocessing um because we're just
stepping through uh single lines of
code.
Okay.
So, this lecture is going to include uh
two parts.
One is we're going to learn about the
building blocks of distributed
communication and computation,
um starting with the uh programming
model, talk a little bit about the
hardware, um start to implement things
in torch, um which you're going to
um
do on your assignment two.
And then, the second part is we're going
to look at actual uh training. Um we're
going to look at three types of
parallelism, uh data parallelism, tensor
parallelism, pipeline parallelism. Each
is going to cut up our model in
different ways. We're going to do this
for um MLPs, um
rather than the full transformer, but
it's really um sort of the core
computation is going to be uh shown
here.
Okay. So,
let's dive in.
So, the first thing to talk about is
these things called collective
operations.
So, collective operations are these uh
primitives from distributed programming
that go back to the '80s. So, the idea
of parallel programming is is very old.
Um it's wasn't invented for LM training.
Um and it's it's still the case that
these primitives are the ones that we um
use um today.
And here collective just means that
you're specifying a general
communication pattern or a template
across multiple devices rather than
managing um point to point how this GPU
is going to communicate with another
GPU.
And this is going to be much um easier
and the system can do a lot more work
for you. So, this is
um
a very tried and true interface for
doing parallel uh programming.
Okay. So, the general setup is as
follows. Um
the terminology here is a little bit I
find a little bit strange, but this is
standard and um
in parallel uh programming.
The idea is that you have a bunch of
ranks, where rank corresponds to a
particular device, in our case a GPU,
could be a TPU. But the point is that
you have let's say four ranks here. The
world size corresponds to the number of
devices. So, the world size here is
four.
Okay. So,
there's a few operations we're going to
go through. Uh broadcast, scatter,
gather, reduce, all gather, reduce,
scatter, all reduce, and all to all. And
each of these operations is going to
specify how this set of ranks or devices
is going to transfer some amount of data
compute with it to some other
set of devices.
So, the first three, broadcast, gather,
gather, reduce, are really just
warm-ups, I would say. They allow you to
get a sense of how these are collective
commission
collective operations work, but they're
not really going to be the ones that are
driving most of training. All gather,
reduce scatter, and all reduce are the
ones that are going to show up again and
again for distributed training of
language models. And finally, all to all
I'll just mention here,
um
uh which is important for MOEs, but
we're not going to actually spend too
much time on this this lecture.
Okay, so let's dive in with the simplest
operation,
which is broadcast.
So, in broadcasting, you have a rank
zero. It could be any rank, but let's
just say for sake of picking one, rank
zero, has some tensor
0 1
0 1 2 3,
and it broadcasts to all the ranks.
So, at the end of this operation,
we have that each of the ranks has the
same tensor on it.
Okay? That should be pretty
straightforward.
Um and this again doesn't really show up
in the that kind of the core path of
training. Generally, broadcasts are used
for initialization where let's say you
know initialize a load initial
checkpoint, and then you want to
broadcast it to all the ranks. So,
something that's done like once.
Okay.
So, the second operation is a scatter,
and a scatter basically says, I have
a tensor
at rank zero,
whose is split up into the world size,
and I'm going to basically scatter my
tensor onto the other ranks.
So, rank zero gets zero Uh, zeroth
component, rank one gets this, rank two
gets this, and rank three gets that.
Okay?
Um, so again, this is not directly used,
but um, scatter is a important stepping
stone to understand reduce scatter. So,
as the name implies, scatter just takes,
um, a big tensor at one place and
spreads it out on onto multiple places.
And you can see how this might be
helpful because you want, uh, all the to
uh, GPUs you're scattering to to do some
local computation on the different
parts.
Okay, so the inverse of scatter is
gather.
Um, so this should be very, uh,
predictable.
Um, the input is you have a dump for a
bunch of pieces, each of which reside on
a particular rank. And then when you do
gather, that's, um, with respect to a
particular rank, rank zero, um, it's
going to just concatenate all the pieces
together.
Okay, again, gather isn't directly used,
but it's going to be a stepping stone to
understand all gather.
So next is, uh, reduce. So, those of you
who do, you know, functional programming
are probably familiar with reduce is,
it's exactly the same. The idea is that
you have, you start in the same starting
point as a, uh, a gather.
Um, and
where the tensor is split up across
multiple, well, you have some piece of
data on each of the different ranks, and
then you're going to apply your
reduction operation to all of these and
get that in, put that on, uh,
rank zero. So in this case, if you, uh,
do a reduction with sum, then you add
these all up, you get six.
Okay? So you can think about gather as a
reduction where the the operation is,
you know, concatenation if you will.
Okay, and of course reduce is important
to understanding all reduce.
Okay, so let me pause there. Um, those
were just kind of the warm-ups just in
case people have any questions about
what a collective operation is,
um,
broadcast
uh, scatter, gather, reduce.
Yeah.
So, the question is is this related to
uh, broadcasting in NumPy?
Um, I mean, I think it's the same I
conceptually the same idea where you
have one thing that goes to many things.
Like in NumPy, if you have a scalar get
broadcast to a tensor, but um, the
instantiation, this is for collective
communication, so it's a bit different.
Okay, so let's uh, move on to something
more interesting. So, all gather
is what you do to basically you perform
gather to all ranks, not just rank zero.
So, remember what gather does? It uh,
basically takes all the different pieces
and it just puts it on one rank, rank
zero.
And now all gather
just does it for every single rank.
Okay, that's what the all word is for.
All means do it for all the output to
all the ranks and gather is what you're
doing to all the ranks.
Okay, so this is going to come up, um, a
bunch. Um, it's not important that you
understand this statement precisely, but
later we'll see that each rank hold part
of the parameters
and then what you need to do is all
gather the parameters to get the full
parameters for the full forward pass.
So, in general, as we're doing training,
we're going to see a lot of this gather
to do something and then scatter and
then gather and scatter again.
Okay. So, reduce scatter
is performing reduce on each dimension
and then scattering, you know, the
results. Okay? So, you have, let's say,
you have um
of, you know, four
uh devices and each of them has some,
you know, vector.
And so, when we did a a reduce before,
we just had 0 1 2 3 and that got reduced
to 6. But now, reduce scatter says that
for each component of this tensor, I'm
going to do a reduction and then I'm
going to put it on a different uh
you know, um you know, uh rank.
So, um the first dimension, I'm going to
add these up, I get six. Um now, for the
second dimension, I'm going to add these
up, I get 10. For the third dimension,
I'm going to process these. For the
fourth dimension, I'm going to process
those.
Okay?
Okay. So, so where this is going to show
up, just as a to foreshadow things, um
after the backward pass, when you sum
uh the what you're going to do is each
uh GPU will be dealing with different
data, right? And what you're doing is
you need to sum all of the gradients um
from the different, you know, shards and
then you're going to distribute
redistribute this, you know, storage.
Okay. And then finally, all reduce, um
if you understand all reduce scatter and
all gather, it's basically you do one
and then you do the other.
Okay. So, what this does is,
um, reduce scatter
uh, the same input as we had, um, you
know, before.
And, um,
remember in reduce scatter we had 6 10
14 and 18 sit on different ranks.
And, uh, the all gather part of all
reduce just puts them all on the same
everything on the same node.
Okay. So, all reduce is in some sense
the easiest to understand. You have a
bunch of tensors, you reduce, in this
case sum, and then you replicate them on
all the nodes.
Okay. So, we're going to see this one
actually first when we do, uh, data
parallel where we sum the gradients, um,
and then we replicate the full, uh, your
parameters.
So, so that's where we're actually going
to start. So, maybe just focus your
attention on all reduce. Later, we're
going to see how, um,
to get, uh, to fancier things like, uh,
zero or FSDP, we need to break the all
reduce into reduce scatter and all
gather.
Because then you can intervene and you
can manage, uh, things a bit more. But,
for the basic,
uh, version, all reduce is is fine.
Okay. Finally, all to all.
This one is the,
in some ways, the most general. You
basically specify how each rank sends,
uh, a particular message to another
rank. Um,
and so, here's a, you know, simple
example where you have the same input
as, you know, before. And what this is
saying is that I want to send zero to
this element to rank, uh, zero.
Um, meaning keep it myself. I'm going to
send one to rank one, two to rank two,
and three to rank three.
And then
uh for if I'm rank one, I want to send
four to rank zero, five to rank one, six
to rank two, and uh seven to rank three.
So basically, the position
here is going to denote where which rank
is going to be the ultimate destination.
And And so if you look at the output,
what happens is that
um
uh the first rank is going to receive
everyone who sent everything in uh
column zero because all these ranks are
sending these things to rank zero. Um
similarly, for rank one, all of the
uh
ranks are sending this column to rank
one, and so on and so forth.
Okay. So, this is going to be useful
when um
for training MOEs, and the
intuition here is that each rank has
both a split of the data and also a
subset of experts. And basically, you in
the key idea of the MOE is that it's
sort of dynamic routing. You have to
look at your data to figure out which
experts
um
are you need to route that um those
activations to.
So, it ends up being a all-to-all uh
communication.
Um
so if you look at
if everything were balanced, meaning
that every rank sent the same number of
uh you know, bytes to this to every
other rank, then all-to-all, you can
think about it as essentially a
transpose. If you think about this as a
matrix, all you're doing is transposing
that matrix.
But in general, all-to-all also handles
unbalanced splits.
Um and I'm not showing this this here,
but you can configure it to send any
number of
you know bytes to any other
another rank.
Um but in general you want the splits to
be as balanced as possible. So remember
Tatsuzou
lecture where we had load balancing to
make sure that things were as balanced
as possible. So morally the ideal goal
is to have thing all to all look kind of
like this.
Okay, so just to summarize
maybe a few helpful tips to remember the
terminology because I just went through
like
quite a few different
um
operations.
So reduce
is well, it's reduced. It performs on
some sort of associative commutative
operation. Could be some, could be max,
could be min.
Um scatter is the inverse of gather.
Scatter distributes, gather centralizes.
And all just means that the destination
is all you know devices. So that
explains all reduce
and all gather.
Okay, let me pause there
to take any questions about collective
communications.
Yeah, for operations such as like gather
and reduce where we like
where we like receive like these smaller
ranks to rank zero. Is that rank zero
the designated like
is it like a particular GPU every time
or can that rank zero change?
Yeah, so the question is when you do a
gather or a reduce, the target
where you
uh write the output, right now I said
rank zero. Um
you'll see later in the code you
basically specify the the
the GPU ID or the the rank. Um and it
goes there. So, it doesn't have to be
determined like way in advance, but it
has to be
determined basically when you
execute the call.
Cool.
Anything else?
Yeah.
These are just like conceptual building
blocks or they're not like actually
things that
like Are they really
These two actually represent
Yeah, so the question is are these just
conceptual building blocks or are they
code? So, I'm showing these right now as
just conceptual building blocks, but
we'll very quickly see how these are
implemented in code.
Okay, so before getting to the code,
um I want to talk a bit about uh the
hardware. In particular, how GPUs are
connected because we already know what's
inside a GPU.
Um
So, you know, let's talk about
networking
um in in general. So, this is kind of a
very classic picture. You can tell from
this uh very old-looking image
um that, you know, this is how computers
used I mean, generally work. So, you
have this uh you know, server and then
you have a bunch of CPUs. There's a PCIE
bus
um which you connect things like your um
or used to connect things like your
mouse and and and keyboard. Um and and
then you have a bunch of GPUs uh sitting
off of them and you have some RAM and
then uh this computer is connected to
Ethernet to another computer um and so
on and so forth.
Okay? So, this is a
particular setup. It has a particular
topology. Um and um
you know, GPUs on the same node you use
PCIE to communicate and GPUs on
different node you have to go all the
way through ethernet.
Okay, so this is like if you bought your
like gaming GPU and you had, you know,
hooked it up with your friend and he's
like, "I'm going to train some big
model."
That's what you would have to do. But,
you know, if you're really serious about
uh training, then
um uh things look more like uh this.
This is the picture I showed in the very
uh you know, beginning where you have
the GPU and there's something called
NVLink and NVLink switch and InfiniBand.
So, uh the typical uh
you know, setup is this. And these
numbers, eight is typical, but this 256
is kind of made up.
So, typically you have eight uh GPUs per
node.
Um and these are connected via um
Nvidia's NVLink to a switch.
Um
and just for kind of calibration, if you
use NVLink uh five, then you're getting
1.8 terabits uh terabytes per second of
total, you know, bandwidth. And
remember, HBM was for B200 was um eight
terabytes per second. So, it's you know,
about four
uh about four x uh slower.
So, I mean, this is still pretty fast if
you think about um going between
devices, but obviously not as fast as uh
high bandwidth memory, which is
much slower than, you know, shared
memory or L1 cache.
Okay?
So, basically uh NVLink connects to the
switch, and which means that um
from a programming perspective, you can
think about GPUs as connected uh to any
other GPU.
Right? You go GPU to any other GPU, and
the hardware takes care of um
transmitting that to the switch and then
the switch routes it.
Okay, so typically what you will also
have is that at some point, you uh you
can't have NV switch and NV link and you
have to because what as your clusters
you know, the number of GPUs grows, then
you're going to have to put these
nodes into pods or
which are connected by InfiniBand.
And the way InfiniBand works is that now
there's a bit you know, more the so now
the the GPU doesn't connect directly to
another GPU, it has to go through PCI E
and uh
and goes through this kind of special
InfiniBand cable and you see that the
the you know, the speeds are much
much lower.
And then finally, if you run out of
InfiniBand and you have these like huge
pods,
um
you know, then you need to connect them
via you know, Ethernet.
And in Ethernet,
um
you know, you have to go through PCI E
and that actually goes through this your
CPU, which as we'll see is um you know,
even even slower.
Okay, so it's kind of analogous to the
kind of memory situation. The more nodes
uh you have, then the slower it's going
to be. You can't have like a NV switch
handling like 100,000, you know, GPUs.
So, one note is that this I mentioned
alluded to this bypassing the CPU, which
is is going to be
uh an important thing from a hardware
perspective.
Um
so, if you have traditional Ethernet,
you know, what happens is that the GPU
has to talk to the CPU to get its uh
data copied. So, it basically has to
copy the data
uh to this uh the CPU has a kernel
socket buffer. Here is kernel means you
know, not the GPU kernel, but the uh the
CPU traditional notion of a kernel,
um and then it has to build some uh some
network packets, copy to the network
interface, and then ship it over. So,
this generally introduces a lot of
latency.
And so, there's this technology called
Remote Direct Memory Access, RDMA, which
allows a GPU to directly write or read
from another uh GPU's memory without
using the CPU at all.
So, obviously, if you're in NVLink land
and NV Switch land, then you have RDMA.
Um InfiniBand also supports RDMA. So, if
you're connected via InfiniBand, then
you can directly uh have GPUs connect to
each other without access uh involving
the CPU.
Uh but standard Ethernet uh does not.
Um there's two
notable advancements I will mention is
that
uh um
So, NVIDIA has been really pushing the
limits on what you can do with larger
and larger, you know, pods. So, they
have for the basically the B200s and the
um
B300s, they have something called NVL72,
which means that they they have these
uh trays of eight GPUs, but have nine of
them. And so, basically, at the end of
the you have 72 GPUs that are all kind
of NV switched into one NVLink domain.
And if you remember
um the NVLink uh
you know, speeds are very fast.
Right? So, normally,
um if you're if you're, you know,
mortal, you think, "Well, okay, I have
eight GPUs that are interlinked really
fast, and then outside of that, you
know, then things get slowed down a
lot." But if you have a lot of money,
you can buy this uh really fancy
hardware, and you can get uh really fast
interconnects up to 72
um GPUs.
And the other thing I'll mention is
that, you know, I said standard Ethernet
doesn't support RDMA, but there has been
progress on the Ethernet front as well.
So, there's something called um
RoCE, RDMA over a converged Ethernet,
where the Ethernet actually bypasses the
the CPU,
um and this is sort of their
their answer to InfiniBand. So,
InfiniBand generally is very ex-
expensive, as is, you know, a lot of
NVIDIA uh products. Um but uh you can
get, you know, pretty good
performance by using um
um
using uh
RDMA over converged Ethernet.
And uh Meta had some papers showing that
they were use exploring this. So,
uh
Llama may or may not have been trained
over uh converged Ethernet.
Okay. So, that's just a kind of brief
overview of what the the hardware uh
looks like. You have GPUs. They're
connect via NVLink to a NV uh switch
over some domain, maybe eight, maybe 72,
and then it's InfiniBand uh from there.
And now,
let's talk about, you know, how do you
program this?
So, at the very lowest level, there's
something called the NVIDIA Collective
Communications Library, uh
NCCL or NCCL, which translates the
collective operations, the all reduce,
uh reduce, broadcast, into the actual
low-level packets that are sent between
GPUs.
So, what uh NCCL does is it um when you
when you use NCCL, it's basically like
saying, "I want to all reduce."
And then NCCL goes and figures out what
is the topology of the hardware, figures
out the the path between different GPUs,
and then it actually launches the GPU
kernels to send and receive data.
Because at the end of the day, remember
everything that runs on the GPU is is a
kernel. So, there are communication
kernels as well that actually do uh you
know, communication with other GPUs.
Okay, so we're not going to look too too
much more into uh nickel, but just know
that it exists.
Um
and then we're going to actually go to
PyTorch. So, maybe before that, any
questions about you know, hardware?
Yeah.
Can you like describe Is there anything
like a rack
Uh
Can I describe physically a rack and a
tray? Like what a rack is and what a
tray is?
Uh so, for the NV
uh 72, so I'm not I'm not a hardware
expert, but
uh
but a rack, I mean, is
literally like I mean, I've I've you've
seen data centers like where you have
like
a rack and each tray is
uh something that has So, it's So, G the
G stands for a grace. So, there's you
know, two CPUs and each CPU is connected
to four GPUs. So, each tray has um eight
uh GPUs on it and they're stacked and
everything, you know, is connected to
this, you know, um
NV switch.
Yeah. Who is responsible for
this one?
Yeah, so the question is what is the
difference between our DMA and this?
Yeah, so RDMA you can think about it as
a more of a
uh a digital router. RDMA means that
like one GPU can read and write from
another GPU's memory. And there's
multiple ways to do RDMA. One is to use
NVLink and NV Switch. And another way is
to use InfiniBand.
So,
InfiniBand and NV Switch and NVLink are
more of the the hardware. Like what what
pieces like what cables are are and
switch is are there.
And RDMA is more
um
operationally like what what happens
when you're communicating.
Yeah, for example, there's an advance
that uh
uh RDMA over converged Ethernet is
another way to do RDMA.
Yeah.
So, the question is is nickel optimized
for multi- node clusters.
Um
So, my
So, I don't know the details of how
you know, they have or have not
optimized it. All I can say is that, you
know, NVIDIA has been basically
you know, optimizing the entire stack
for, you know, inference and training of
these large um models because their main
customers are the kind of major
um
you know, providers of language models.
So, I would be surprised if they haven't
thought of uh optimizing for those type
of workloads.
Yeah.
So, uh question is what happens if you
have nine GPUs? How do you distribute
the workload across those?
Um
I I suppose
I guess it kind of depends on how the
nine lands in your your setup. For
example, a lot of times you'll have
um you know, let's say you have eight
GPUs per node. So, then the ninth one
would be on a different node. And if you
don't have um
you know, NVLink connecting them, then
that's going to be really bad because
that's going to be one node which is not
providing that much compute and also
very expensive to communicate with.
Um but if you let's say had a um
everything were connected by NVLink, you
know, switch, then it would be
um much more reasonable.
Okay. Um one more question and I'm going
to move on. Yeah.
TPUs?
So, how is this different from uh TPUs?
Um so, how to describe TPUs a bit uh
more. So,
um
I mean, the let's see.
Um what can I say quickly about this? Um
so, TPUs are generally kind of much
uh you know, simpler objects.
Um I'm not too familiar with the details
of how this like what this each of these
components corresponds to, but maybe we
can talk about it offline.
Okay. So, let's actually get down to
some code to um
take advantage of this this hardware.
So, PyTorch conveniently has a
torch.distributed library
that provides a clean interface into
these collective operations.
So you don't have to explicitly think
about nickel um
And in fact, this library also supports
different backends for different
hardware. So if you are on GPUs, then
you would use the nickel backend. And if
you are on CPUs, then there's something
called glue, which uh still allows you
to you know, like I said,
parallel processing has been around for
um you know, a long time before GPUs,
and you can do um these collective
operations on CPUs as well.
Um
This library also supports higher-level
models and algorithms such as uh
uh SFTP, but we're not going to use
those in the course because we're
building things from scratch.
All right. So
let's walk through some basic examples
of collective operations.
Um so this this function called uh
spawn, which takes uh another function
I'm going to call, and it says, "I'm
going to run this
uh replicated four times, where four is
the world size." So let's see what this
does.
Um this is actually a wrapper I wrote um
just to
sort of hack around the fact that I
can't do multiprocessing in this uh this
lecture. So normally, what you would do
is you call uh
um
you know, torches.multiprocessing.spawn,
then you call the function. Um but you
know, I'm going to do this branch, which
dis- dis- disables distributed. So let's
just go through that.
So now um now I'm in this uh function
that it's supposed to be running on
asynchronously for each process. So
remember, world size is the number of
processes,
and the rank is either zero or one or
two all the way up to world size minus
one.
And so there are world size number of
these functions that are or each running
on a process at the same time.
Okay, so I'm on uh rank zero right now.
So, what do I do?
Um there's a setup. Um you basically
configure uh
the the master
address and port. Um
notice that this is not actually how the
the GPUs are going to communicate. This
is more for just general metadata and
coordination. So, data goes through
nickel. Otherwise, it'll be very very
slow.
Um and if you have CUDA available, then
you can use the nickel back end. Um I'm
on my laptop, so I'm going to use uh the
glue back end.
Okay, so
um so, now I'm here. I'm running
um
you know, pretend I have four of these
processes running.
Um so, there's this uh barrier function,
which
um is useful as uh it's a
synchronization barrier. So, basically,
if I see this, then it waits for all the
processes to get to this point.
Um
okay?
So, basically, you can think of all the
processes are running asynchronously. Um
so, I don't really control one could
completely finish before the other. They
might uh finish be interleaving anyway.
So, if I want to make sure that certain
there's some
code that is executed before other code,
I put these uh synchronization barriers
in.
So, now the downside of putting more
barriers in is that, well, you end up
kind of waiting uh potentially
unnecessarily.
Okay, so let's try an all reduce. Okay,
so I'm going to
um
create this tensor 0 1 2 3.
And um
I have my rank. Just to make it more
interesting, each rank is uh going to
have a different tensor.
Um I'm going to print out what I have
before the all reduce. So, now I'm going
to
skip over here and see what gets printed
out.
Um
so,
uh rank zero before all reduce has 0 1 2
3.
Um rank one has 1 2 3 4 and so on. It's
the same example as I showed before.
Notice that the print statements are
coming in whatever order
uh the hardware feels like it because
it's running a sync,
but all the data is there.
Okay.
So, now if I do a all reduce and uh this
you pass in
This is a PyTorch function. It passes in
this this tensor. You pass in the
reduction operation, which is a sum.
And I'm going to say don't do it uh a
sync.
And what this does is it calls um in
this case it would be glue, but it could
be nickel. And which in which case it
would spin up the the CUDA kernels. It
would do the communication. It takes
care of everything for you.
And then it basically writes in place to
the data.
So, after the all reduce um I have the
all reduce operation. Remember, which is
the sum of each of these columns, but
replicated across all the ranks.
Okay.
So, so that's you know, all reduce. And
if you want to do be you know, fancier
and do a sync, then you could say a sync
equals true. But then it would screw up
all these print statements. So, I'm
trying to put more barriers than I would
normally would.
Yeah, question.
Uh so, the question is the rank of the
GPU.
Uh
for this class, the rank is uh the GPU.
Yes.
Okay, so let's try another example here.
So I'm going to do a reduced scatter.
So here
I'm going to create an input which is
zero through the the world size.
And I'm going to
have
the the output. I'm going to allocate
the output.
And so what does this look like before I
do the reduced scatter?
It looks like
let's see
this
where each it's kind of the same you
know input and the output is happens to
be zeros but it could be you know just
anything.
And then I do the reduced scatter
tensor. Here instead of writing in place
I have a output tensor and an input
tensor. I say I want to you know do the
sum.
And then afterwards
I get
basically the input is not touched but
the output I get the
the reduction of each component written
into the respective ranks.
Okay, so yeah, question.
Yeah, so the question is how does it
work to do the all reduces asynchronous?
So what this means is that this this is
sort of like a monolithic operation. You
say go do the all reduce and it's
spinning up you know know, kernels. It's
going to
you know, do the communication. And uh
remember CUDA is already kind of a sync
um
with respect to the process processes,
and now we have all the processes being
a sync. And the point is that um this
code just would return.
Um
and and then you could do kind of other
things. So, a typical thing
um which I'm not going to have uh talk
about this class is overlapping
computation and communication. Uh so,
for example, you can do this um
operation, and then you can go ahead and
load some other data for the next uh
step.
Um which is independent of this
operation.
And then when you want to make sure that
you actually um
are done, then you can call wait or a a
barrier.
Okay. So, let's do the final one, which
is all gather. So, by now, I think you
kind of get the idea. Here, I'm going to
set as the input the output of the
reduce scatter.
Um I'm going to allocate an output.
Uh so, before
the all gather, it looks like this. I
have my
uh result from the reduce scatter here.
Um the output is uh
you know, it just allocated, happens to
have some values in it, but don't you
know, worry
uh about it. Um
And then
um after I do the all gather into
tensor,
um
and then I will have
you know, all the different uh inputs
uh
you know,
gathered onto all the different ranks.
Okay? And you can see here that indeed
uh proof via example that all reduce is
equal to reduce scatter plus all gather.
Okay.
And then um just to wrap things up, just
as I started by a setup then I clean up
um which, you know,
uh just
um
it's good practice to clean up.
Okay.
So so that was your first example of a
torch uh distributed, you know, program.
Okay. So, let's do um some
um
you know, benchmarking. Uh this will be
quick since I want to actually move on
to the uh part two.
Um so, how fast does communication
happen?
So, let's do an all reduce. Um so, here
I'm going to
all reduce with
you know, 100 million um elements.
And oops.
Okay. Let me Sorry, mess this up.
Okay. So, all reduce
So, I'm going to create
uh
you know, this this tensor with this
number of elements, call um and remember
just like before when we do
benchmarking, we warm up first. Um and
here I'm going to call the CUDA
synchronize and also the the barrier
um just to make sure that because
there's two forms of asyncrony here, the
CUDA kernels and the different
processes, and just want to make sure
everything is
kind of uh not
running in the
um is is done
um before I start the time and I'm going
to do the all reduce
um
and
and then uh wait uh again with the
synchronizing the barrier, and stop the
time.
Okay, so
remember this is running for every
single rank. So, if I look at the output
here,
for rank 0 2 1 3,
I have a different time potentially
because they're all different processes.
Each of them is going to report a
certain
um
you know, measurement. And if you want
to report one number, you can take the
average, for example.
Um
So, now, one thing that is useful to do,
which is analogous to when we were
computing MFU, is to compute measure the
effective bandwidth.
And the idea here is that well, this
took 1.6 milliseconds.
You know, how much
um
you know, is that good or bad?
So, to compute the effective bandwidth,
what we're going to do is to compute
essentially how much how many bytes were
sent
and should be sent kind of during this
computation. Um and then you if you
divide by the total time, then you get
the bad effective bandwidth.
Okay, so
um the size of what I'm sending around
is the
the size of each element times the
number of elements, so that's the
basically the number of bytes of this
data tensor.
Um how many bytes get actually sent? So,
this uh needs some unpacking.
So,
for all reduce, um
if you think about, let's just say for
simplicity, you do a rank 0 plus rank 1
plus rank 2 plus rank 3, um you need to
iterate this world size minus one steps
because there's a world size minus one,
you know, addition operations. The So,
that's this factor.
There's a two because you need to both
kind of send and reduce. So, and then
you multiply by the size of the payload.
So, that's the total number of sent
bytes.
And the total duration um is the the
time that the wall clock time that it
took.
And then you multiply by the the world
size um because it's like the total
amount that the all the ranks have
waited.
And the bandwidth is the the
um the bytes sent divided by the total,
you know, duration.
Okay, so in this case,
uh you get something like, you know,
about 400 GB uh you know, per second.
Okay?
So,
one uh a few notes here.
One is that the effective bandwidth, if
you look at this expression, size * 2 *
world size - 1 / world size * duration,
so as world size increases, this uh
world my size - 1 / world size
essentially converges to one. So, you're
effectively left with two times the size
bytes over the duration.
So, this is essentially uh the
bandwidth. Notice that this is
independent of the world size,
which is which is good. So, if you grow
the number of GPUs you have, you are
still, you know, the bandwidth doesn't,
you know, change.
It is also independent of the topology,
which is something that kind of nickel
uh you know, figures out whether you're
um going to uh pass the messages in a
kind of a ring or a tree topology.
Um
so,
yeah.
Okay, so that is
uh all reduce. And for reduce scatter,
um this is very similar.
Um
so, I'm going to create the inputs and
the outputs, warm up, uh perform the
operation, and time it.
So,
uh notice that the reduce scatter has uh
this
um these timings. Um
And
and you can also measure the effective
bandwidth here. The number of bytes uh
that were
uh
in the input,
you have the number of bytes that were
sent. Here there is no um you know, 2x
here.
Um and then the total duration, you
divide by that, you get the bandwidth.
So, here the bandwidth is
uh
um it should be very similar. I guess
sometimes there's some stochasticity,
but it's on in the kind of 400s.
So, a few notes here.
A all reduce is, remember as we stated,
reduce scatter plus an all gather.
And so, all reduce naturally is moving
twice the amount of data
um because reduce scatter is like has
some cost, all gather has some cost, and
all reduce is doing twice as much work.
Um
but and it takes twice the amount of
time.
Um but you know, the two cancel out, so
you get the the same kind of bandwidth.
Okay.
All right. So, um that is the end of
part one. Maybe
any questions before I move to part two?
Yeah.
So, why do we have to do the synchronize
for the CUDA kernel?
So, at the end of the day, we are still
doing CUDA operations.
Right? We have just multiple processes,
each with a GPU,
um doing some CUDA
operations.
And then, so if you're doing a CUDA
operation, remember by default it's
async. So, when you reach the next line
in Python, that CUDA operation might not
be done.
So, we need to wait always until that's
to make sure it's done by synchronizing.
Yeah.
So, do you have to do barrier first and
then synchronize?
Um
not sure.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think one problem is if you
barrier first and then
the CUDA might not be done
running and you just immediately go to
the barrier.
And then, you are still kind of each
independently synchronizing the
different CUDA kernels.
Which means that you're not really
synchronized. Um like the barrier might
if all those uh operations just return,
the barrier doesn't really do any thing.
Okay, let me move on. So, now let's
actually start thinking about how you
train models. Okay? So, we're just going
to walk through a very bare-bones
implementation of training MLPs,
multi-layer MLPs.
Um I guess that's redundant. It's
multi-layer perceptrons already. Um
and remember that MLPs are the ones that
are the actual compute bottleneck in a
transformer, so this is actually pretty
representative of what you'll see.
Okay. So, data uh parallelism, tensor
parallelism, and pipeline parallelism.
And the picture I want to
uh you to have in your head is this
picture. So, um this is a little bit of
a schematic, so don't think too deeply
about this, but it's more of a way to
conceptualize how you're cutting um your
data and parameters.
So, data parallelism says, "I'm going to
split the data
into pieces, and then each of the GPUs
is going to be responsible for part of
the data, and I'm going to do just do
normal uh you know, I'm going to act
keep track of all the parameters and do
model normal model, you know, training."
Um
and then I need to synchronize. So, let
me explain how this how this works. So,
I'm going to generate some sample data.
So, there's a batch size of 128, number
of dimensions 1,024.
So, this is a batch size by num dim uh
matrix
data matrix.
And uh let's jump into
this uh data parallelism.
Okay? So, the way that it's going to
work is that you have this data matrix,
and I'm going to break up the rows into
a bunch of um into num world size
pieces,
in this case four, and each
uh rank is going to get a piece.
Okay? So, the number of dimensions, the
batch size, um
so, each I'm going to call the local
batch size, basically
um
you know, the batch size divided by the
world size, which is every row is going
to have that uh GPU sees is going to
have 32
um you know, data points.
Um and this is just indexing start index
uh data
start to end gets you the slice of that
data and I'm going to just put it on
that um
on that rank.
Okay, so at this point each GPU has now
a distinct data tensor which is the part
that they're uh responsible for.
Now in practice uh each rank should
probably load its own data rather have
this you know this bottleneck but um
this is just for illustrative purposes.
Okay, so let's uh instantiate the the
MLP.
So here
I'm uh
assume we have num layers
um
and uh num layers
uh
and for each of the layers I'm going to
have just a num dim by num dim um
matrix.
Um
so I'm just going to initialize a random
you know set of parameters.
Um and then um
I'm going to feed that into optimizer.
Okay?
So here's the training loop.
So in the forward pass I take the data.
So remember data is
not the all the data. It's just um if
I'm rank two then I only get B2 part of
the data.
I'm going to just you know go through
the number of layers and uh do a forward
pass.
And then I'm going to do a backward
And then normally this would be it.
But um
now remember every rank has different
data.
Therefore, the gradients are going to be
you know different
as well.
So this is the key uh step that makes uh
data parallelism work. We're going to
synchronize the gradients across all the
workers. This is only difference between
standard training and DDP. It's actually
pretty nice and elegant. So basically
for all the parameters, I'm going to do
a all reduce
of
um
param.grad.
And I'm going to average.
Um and then after this all reduce is
done,
then
now at this point, each of the ranks has
the exact same gradients.
And then I'm just going to update uh the
the parameters.
Okay?
So, it's kind of really kind of elegant
I find because it's basically standard
training
where are you apply it to your local
batch, but
um you just insert this after the
backward pass. Let's just, you know,
average all the gradients via this all
reduce. It's a one-line, you know,
uh code change. And then the parameters
get updated. So, as you're training,
each um rank is
basically performing parameter updates
as if it were have all the data on it,
but it's only actually processing a part
of the data.
Okay. So, that's uh basically uh DDP or
um
the first type of data parallel.
Any questions about this?
Yeah.
So, the question is can you only do this
with batch size greater than one?
Uh yes. So, your batch size has to be at
least world size for this to really make
sense. And usually it should probably be
quite a bit larger.
Yeah.
Yeah. So, the question is should the um
batch size be a multiple of world size?
And that's also would be nice.
Yes.
I mean, if it's not, then you can pad it
with zeros or something. So, there's
ways, but it's just easier
for everyone if it is.
Uh yeah, so the question is what it
would this look like for a transformer?
It would actually be basically the the
same.
The DDP has a nice thing that is very
modular. You do the forward pass.
I mean, DDP just averages the parameters
here. It doesn't care what your forward
pass looks like.
Okay.
Let me move on.
Okay, so that's DDP.
Um so,
just to summarize, the losses are
different across the ranks.
Um the gradients are also,
you know, initially different,
but they're all reduced to be the same
across the ranks,
and therefore the parameters all remain
the same across ranks.
Okay. So, next lecture Tatsu is going to
talk about fancier uh data parallelism,
FSDP and zero, and the idea there is, as
I've alluded to, here we use all reduce.
It's like a very simple monolithic
operation, but it does require holding
all the models parameters in memory.
But what if the model parameters don't
fit in memory?
Then you're going to have to be more
clever, and that's the topic for next
class.
Okay.
So, let me talk about tensor
parallelism.
So, here the idea is we're going to cut
this way. I mean, we're not going to cut
the data, we're going to cut um the
essentially
uh each layer.
And so, each rank is going to get part
of each layer.
Okay?
And generally this rem-
means that we're going to have to
transfer a a lot more more data. We're
going to discuss this a bit later.
Um
So what does
tensor parallel look like?
Okay. So
um we're just going to assume we have
this data. Every rank has all the data
um
just for simplicity. And here, remember
the the data is batch size times num
dim.
And I'm going to define a local num dim
to be for this
uh rank, I only am
um
responsible for a subset of the the
dimensions.
So uh the kind of the picture here is
that um each model still has all the
layers here for all the layers, but the
parameters now are num dim
times uh local num dim.
Okay? So if this were one of the
parameter matrices for one layer,
um I would be doing um splitting down uh
the columns.
Okay? So this is also known as column uh
you know, tensor parallel.
You can also do it by rows, but we're
not going to talk about that right now.
Okay. So now what does the forward pass
uh look like?
So go through all the layers and I'm
going to compute activations.
So
um
I start with uh
you know, X, the data.
And I'm going to access the parameters
at
layer
uh layer.
And notice that this is only a slice of
the the
right? So if I'm on rank one, I only get
this part of uh the matrix.
But, you know, I can still proceed. I
can apply this non-linearity because
this is element-wise anyway.
Uh but now,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
um
you know, communicate activations.
So, if I have a data matrix, rank one
has activations for part of the
activations uh for this part of the
matrix.
Um rank one has part of the activations
for this matrix, and so on and so forth.
And I need to basically
put all the activations on all the um
the ranks.
And but we know how to do that. We
introduced all gather
as a collective uh primitive. So, I have
This is all the
the activations.
Um so, this is um you know, the batch
size times local num um dim, which is
the shape of the of the activations.
Um
and
then I'm doing a all gather.
Um
Sorry. So, this is the allocating memory
for the activations. So, X is the actual
part of the activation. So, this is
batch size times local num dim.
And all gather says each rank has X,
and
each uh rank is going to allocate
activations, um
uh which is a list, one for each world
size. And then after the all gather, X
is going to be copied into each of the
respective location activations.
Okay. So, then um once I gather all the
activations, I concatenate them to form
the full uh dimensional X, which is
batch size times num dim.
Okay.
Um any questions about
column tensor parallel?
So, this is done for every layer.
Um
we've
Now, notice one difference between uh
data parallel is now we have to kind of
muck around with the model.
Data parallel is very elegant because
it's splitting by data. The model is
treated as a as a module.
Uh but now we have to muck around with a
model.
Um and
you know, this is sort of strongly
leveraging the fact that if you want to
do a matrix multiplication, you can
split it up into a set of small matrix
small smaller matrix multiplications.
You can do those on different ranks, and
then we can gather the the results.
Yeah, so so now
the question is what happens in back
prop. Now, in the back prop, you have
your your activations, and you have to
uh reduce uh scatter to all the
different um
you know, gradients. So, in some ways,
all gather and reduce scatter have this
kind of duality where in forward, if
you're all gathering in the backward,
you're reduce scattering.
Yeah.
So, the question is is that done
automatically by autograd? So, none of
this Well, okay.
So, if you just call dot backward, it's
not going to do it because there's no
parallelism in that, but you know,
PyTorch has all these
things that are done automatically for
you. So,
um
>> So, in this So, what hack is done for U
and versus automatically? Um here we're
managing things fairly explicitly. So,
which means I'm not doing the backward
pass, but you would have to manage and
call the the reduce scatter yourself.
Yeah.
And that's baked in by design because
this is 336 uh you know, building
language models from scratch. In
practice, you probably wouldn't have to
do that.
Okay. So, let's do pipeline parallelism
uh quickly.
So, the idea behind pipeline parallelism
is we're going to split the network this
way. So, each um rank is going to get a
subset of the layers now.
Within each layer, it's going to get all
the the dimensions. And it's also going
to get all the
um well,
the one of the ranks is going to get all
the data.
Um it will it's going to every rank is
going to see all the data in some form.
Um so, this is the the way it's going to
work. Um
Okay. So, let's
um we have all the data, which is again
uh the batch size times num dim.
Um
and I'm going to split up the layers.
So, local num layers is going to be the
number of layers that a particular rank
is going to handle.
Um and
and so, I'm now I'm going to have local
params uh which is basically only
there's local number of layers number of
them.
But, within each layer, I'm going to do
the you know, num dim by num dim.
Okay. So,
um one thing I
um
maybe Tatsu will talk more about this on
uh Wednesday is this idea of micro
batches.
Um, so maybe I'll just present this and
explain why I'm doing things this way.
So, in addition to splitting up the
layers, I'm also going to split up the
batch into a bunch of micro batches.
Um, so if I'm rank zero, then I get the
data. Um,
and I'm going to chunk it up into number
of micro batches.
Um, and
for each
um,
you know, micro batch,
what I'm going to do is
uh, receive
it from the previous rank.
Um, and then
do the feed forward pass only on the
layers that are assigned to this rank.
And then I'm going to send to the next,
uh,
you know, rank.
Okay, so here I'm actually using these
receive and send, which are point-wise
operations. I So, I didn't cover those
before, but they're fairly,
um, explanatory. This basically says
I'm rank, and I'm going to send this
tensor over to, um,
you know, uh, oh, sorry. I'm going to
receive this tensor from rank minus one.
Um, and this says I'm going to send
tensor X to rank plus one.
Um,
okay.
So,
so basically the reason why
um,
I'm talking about micro batches is, uh,
and Toshi will talk more about this, uh,
on Wednesday, is that in pipeline
parallelism, so you have one rank that
gets the data. It processes some of the
layers, and then it sends it to the
next, um,
you know, GPU, and it processes some of
the layers and it then it sends it to
the next GPU.
Right? So, this is a very natural way of
dividing our deep network, but the
problem is that you get these what are
called pipeline bubbles where
um, while
you're not
um, sort of processing, you're kind of
waiting around for other tensors to
process. And this is ends up being quite
inefficient. So, the idea behind uh,
micro batches is that you break it up
into smaller batches so you can kind of
process it quickly, send it on to the
next one. So, this can reduce the number
of uh, pipeline now bubbles.
Okay, so the other thing I will mention
that is not handled in this very kind of
naive version is the idea of overlapping
communication and computation, which is
actually very important to
pipeline parallelism. This basically
gives you the right structure. If you
put a I uh, before these, then it
becomes um,
kind of async. Um, you you have to add
more things to kind of manage the the
uh, the code. Um, and the idea here is
that
you want to be while you're computing
here,
um, you should you know, you can be
receiving um, data or sending data.
So, computation and communication should
be overlapped so uh, that reduces amount
of time um, you're actually spent
waiting.
Okay.
So, a few things that are kind of um,
you know, missing here, uh, which will
uh, hopefully fill in next time. So, the
communication versus computation
overlap, which is
uh, especially crucial in pipeline
parallelism. Um, I didn't mention uh, in
data parallelism this also um, happens
because I just did a full repass and
then at the end I'm just doing all these
all reduces. But if you're clever, then
on the backward pass, as soon as the
gradients are done, you can start
sending that.
And that's something you'll be exploring
in the assignment two.
And this again allows you to just, you
know, overlap communication and
computation, um, more.
Um, we
had some questions about what about
general models? Again, I think this
um, MLP gives you essentially all you
um,
you know, mostly of most of kind of what
you need for understanding the, you
know, the basics.
Um, some of the larger models just
require a lot more bookkeeping, so um,
it's harder to kind of see the core core
algorithms.
Um, there are other types of parallelism
that we haven't covered. Um, so sequence
parallelism takes a whole, you know,
sequence and chops it up into pieces and
that allows you to parallelize attention
computation,
expert parallelism, which, um,
allows you to parallelize, uh, the
experts for MOEs and this is where the
all-to-all that I mentioned comes in.
And then also,
you know,
uh, you know, different combinations of,
uh, different parallelization
techniques, which also will show up in
the assignment.
Um,
so
one thing to note is that
the which parallelism technique you
choose is going to be strongly dependent
on the hardware. For example, tensor
parallelism, there's a lot of
communication because for every layer
you're just, you know, you need to send
all these activations which are fairly
big. So generally tensor parallelism
happens within a node on NVLink or NV,
uh, where you have high bandwidth.
Um,
whereas you wouldn't do tensor
parallelism the kind of an NVLink uh,
you know domain.
Um whereas uh pipeline parallelism,
you'll see people using it and generally
this is can tolerate much uh you know
slower you know uh interconnects. So,
some of the decentralized um training
work uses pipeline parallel because your
you know nodes are GPUs are actually
across halfway across the world. Um but
you wouldn't want to do tensor parallel
in that that setting.
Um so, sometimes
you when you look at these combinations,
it'll be tensor parallel within a node
and then
um
and then uh you know pipe data parallel
or SFDP and then
um
and then uh you know pipeline
parallelism if you if you need it.
Um there's other effects such as if you
do data parallel, you might be able to
do data parallel
uh quite a bit, but then you start
hitting to something called the critical
batch fact uh size where if you start
increasing the batch size too much, it
doesn't actually help you, in which case
you're just kind of wasting your compute
and then you're better off using tensor
parallel. So, there's a bunch of these
considerations which um we'll talk more
about as we uh go through the class.
Um so, final note uh so, TPUs kind of
came up a little bit.
Um one thing to to note is that
on purpose, we are using PyTorch and not
just using PyTorch, but really using the
collective uh operations in a very
primitive way. So, you can see uh
mechanically what's happening.
Another approach, uh especially if
you're JAX and TPU land, is that you can
simply define the model and the starting
strategy and the compiler actually
handles a lot of um
the
the decision of how to
basically what kind of communicated
operations you need. You basically say,
well, this piece of data needs to be
here and here and here and then the
compiler does
some magic to figure out what.
So, that's appealing but, you know,
obviously it would take a lot of the you
know, the joy out of actually building
things from scratch.
Okay.
Uh just to summarize. So,
there's many ways to parallelize. You
can cut by data, cut by tensor, or
expert, cut by pipeline, or sequence.
We looked at data parallelism.
We only did DDP. Next time we'll do FSDP
and zero.
Tensor parallelism, as I mentioned,
requires very fast internet connects.
Pipeline, less so.
But you need to really work hard to
reduce these pipeline you know, bubbles.
And then maybe at a high level we see
this kind of
pattern come up a lot. Right? So, you
can either recompute
or store in memory.
When we were talking about things like
activation checkpointing or
doing
you know, when we're working with GPUs.
Or in this case, you can think about an
extension of this is that you can store
on a different you know, GPU.
Right? From that perspective, you look
at the data parallel. Right? You're
doing redundant work. In some sense,
because every
you know, rank is actually updating its
parameters and keeping track of all the
parameters. But the reason you're doing
that is that you don't have to move the
optimizer state across.
Um
So, you know, one thing is that, you
know, hardware is getting, you know,
faster, but
in some sense, we'll always want, you
know, bigger models. So, this idea of
having a hierarchical structure will,
you know, always be there.
Okay, so that's it for today. So, uh
next Wednesday, Tatsuo will uh do more
of a deep dive on uh more parallelism
techniques.
Okay.